hey what's up everybody its Anna Mac and
this is going to be a quick response
video this past friday pewdiepie the
biggest youtuber of all time made a
video called why am i so embarrassed now
this title made me curious because i
watch his videos and he's done some
crazy stuff in the past like he's made a
video where he was waxing his own chest
while playing a game in which you get to
wax David Hasselhoff's chest so that's
pretty embarrassing right there so you
know I had no idea what this video could
be about like did he give away all his
money to a Nigerian prince who contacted
him by email like I had no idea I had to
find out so yeah let's see let's just
see what it's about oh boy am I gonna
regret this video I'm gonna talk about
my favourite anime videos is
embarrassing what the [ __ ]
embarrassing know if you actually watch
PewDiePie you already know that he's a
big anime fan it's not a secret
and he's made videos with anime content
before but he seems to be embarrassed to
make a video where he just talks about
his favorite anime for some reason he
seems to think that making a video in
which he just talks about the anime that
he likes is like nerdy or weird or
embarrassing in some way no after this
video came out a lot of anime fans were
confused they weren't sure if PewDiePie
was saying that liking anime is
embarrassing that they should be
embarrassed that they like anime so it
generated quite a lot of controversy on
YouTube a few days after PewDiePie's
video Joey the anime man uploaded a
separate video in which he kind of tries
to interpret what PewDiePie was trying
to say and in this video
Joey says that he doesn't think the
PewDiePie was actually embarrassed of
liking anime he says that he thinks that
a PewDiePie was embarrassed to talk
about something so personal to them in
front of so many people so talk about
the really the anime that he grew up
with that he really cares about that hid
that kind of shaved him in some way in
the video joey actually mentions that
pewdiepie has liked anime for a long
time of course and that even subscribes
to Joey's channel and what do you know
PewDiePie himself made an appearance
right there in the comments section of
Joey's video and he basically said that
what Joey was saying is spot-on meaning
that what PewDiePie was really
embarrassed about was the personal
aspects of talking about your favorite
anime in front of so many people he was
not embarrassed about liking anime in
you know what that's fair enough that's
fair enough but I still kind of have a
hard time understanding why anybody
would be embarrassed to talk about their
favorite anime why is this too personal
why is this embarrassing cuz you know
what let me get a little bit personal
with you guys this is gonna be hard I
really like Gurren Lagann on our backs
and in our hearts baby on our backs it
in our hearts maybe that was a little
embarrassing so yeah at the end I don't
know if PewDiePie was embarrassed of
liking anime or he was just embarrassed
to talk about something personal or
whatever it was but this whole thing got
me thinking about you know in general
should we be embarrassed about liking
anime why would anyone be embarrassed of
liking anime or talking about anime in
any way I feel like there are two main
reasons why someone like PewDiePie would
be embarrassed to liking anime or
talking about anime in today's world the
first reason that I can think of is that
PewDiePie obviously has millions and
millions of fans around the world and he
wants to live up to the expectations of
those fans he doesn't want to disappoint
that now what does that have to do with
anime well we know that for the past
year or so the whole weeaboo or Reba
meme has been going around online all
over the place and especially on YouTube
and if you ever seen YouTube comments
you'll know what I mean about a year ago
youtuber filthy Frank made a video in
which he talks about weeaboos and this
is basically fans of anime from the West
who take the fandom away too far who
start thinking that they're Japanese
acting like they're Japanese rejecting
their own culture and all this kind of
stuff which is an obviously extreme sort
of obsessive way to look at anime now
that video has nearly 50 million views
and since that video became popular it
also became popular to call anyone who
likes anime a weeb or a weeaboo that
seems to be like a popular trend on
YouTube now and it's been going on for
quite a few months basically you see
anyone in the comments who has an anime
profile picture or says anything about
an anime or says that they like anime
and right away you're gonna see a bunch
of comments saying weeb weeb weeaboo
you're a weeaboo and it's like what like
if these guys even seen the actual
filthy frank video like let's see what
he actually says about weaboos for those
of you who don't know what a weeaboo is
a non-japanese person who basically
denounces their own culture and call
themselves Japanese they try to learn
Japanese through the anime they watch
and usually end up pronouncing
looking like a complete idiot keep in
mind but a non-japanese person can like
the culture watch out and they speak the
language and respect the culture well
still keeping in touch with their own
which keeps them from being a weeaboo so
yeah from this it's clear that the
massive massive majority of anime fans
are not weeaboos I don't personally even
know anyone who's a weeaboo I don't know
anyone who rejects their own culture and
pretends to be Japanese like that's
insane the fact is that the vast
majority of people throwing out words
like we've been weeaboo online today and
especially on YouTube have no idea what
they're talking about and they probably
didn't even see the filthy frank video
they're just kind of jumping on the mean
train so this is one of the reasons that
I think someone like PewDiePie with a
huge following might be self-conscious
about talking about anime even though he
shouldn't be because he's not a weeaboo
he absolutely has nothing to do with
weeaboos and anyone who calls him a
weeaboo or we've doesn't know what
they're talking about now the second
reason that I think someone might be
self-conscious or embarrassed to talk
about anime are to popular
misconceptions that we have here in
Western culture about what anime is now
on the one hand we have the
misconception that all cartoons are
childish that all cartoons are for kids
so if you watch cartoons any type of
cartoons you must be childish - you must
be refusing to grow up on the other hand
we have the misconception that all anime
is perverted and that if you watch anime
you must be some kind of pervert the
irony in all of this is that these two
misconceptions are actually opposites of
each other so how can anime on the one
hand be childish and only for children
and on the other hand be perverted and
inappropriate for children the truth is
actually very simple
anime is a diverse medium there are
anime out there which are childish
because they're geared towards children
there are also anime out there that are
geared towards adults and they're part
of the adult entertainment industry
which is why they're actually considered
perverted by some people but the fact is
that the vast majority of anime are
neither just for children nor are they
pornographic anime has something for
everyone
there are anime for kids anime for teens
anime for tweens and there are also
anime that are specifically made for
adults and they feature the kind of
mature teams that you would never let
your children watch
there are anime out there with lots of
fanservice and there are also anime with
no fanservice
there are anime that are about
highschool romance and they're also
anime that are about mass murderers and
war and violence an anime can be science
fiction fantasy historical fiction
romance slice of life and so
just like a Hollywood movie or a cable
TV series the point is that anime is not
just one genre anime is a diverse medium
with many different genres just like you
can't judge Hollywood movies in general
based on rom-coms you can judge all of
anime based on one or two animate a use
sign you thought were childish imagine
if a Japanese person who grew up
watching anime saw M night Shyamalan The
Last Airbender and decided based on that
one film that all Hollywood movies were
a shitty uninspired disaster of course
you can't judge all Hollywood movies
based on that one shitty movie that will
be ridiculous the truth is that most of
those people who go around hating on
anime have no idea what anime actually
is they don't understand it they think
that because anime doesn't play any part
in their lives and because it comes from
a culture that is foreign to them that
it should be ridiculed and that people
from this culture the Western culture
who like it should also be ridiculed but
that of course is insane no one should
criticize a Japanese person for liking a
great Hollywood movie and no one should
criticize a Western anime fan for liking
a great anime so yeah guys those are
just some of my thoughts on this whole
issue and PewDiePie if you're watching
of course you're not watching no one's
watching oh yeah guys just in general
don't fall into the trap of being
embarrassed about liking anime just
because some people out there don't
understand anime and don't know what
it's about
you should be proud and you should help
spread awareness about what a creative
and unique medium anime is and who knows
maybe someone else will hear what you
have to say and they're gonna check out
anime and discover a whole new world
that wasn't open to them before so yeah
that's it for me thank you very much for
watching and if you have thoughts on
this issue please leave it in the
comments I'd love to hear what you think
and yeah if you like this type of
content subscribe for more